have you spoken to your brother since
the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do i
think everyone hopes that the brothers
will
be able to heal this rift clearly it
does run
deep i mean i think it speaks volumes
that william hasn't yet
picked up the phone to his brother i
think clearly
he's needed some cooling off time he was
simply so angry over the interview and
the fact that
the duchess of cambridge kate had been
dragged into it
all but i think the feeling is that
time is is a healer that's something
that harry himself
said the relationship is space
at the moment and you know time
heals all things hopefully i can't
imagine that both brothers won't be at
the unveiling of the statue for diana in
july
she she said she always wanted her boys
to be close
and i think people saw an unbreakable
bond between those boys
things have come to blows they the
relationship is clearly under a lot of
strain
but hopefully behind closed doors that
can begin to heal
i'm told that prince harry hasn't yet
booked his ticket home now that may have
more to do with pandemic and
travel restrictions than it does this
family rift which has blown up in the
wake of the oprah interview
certainly it's everyone's intention at
kensington palace that
the brothers really need to be shoulder
by shoulder
for the unveiling of the statue which is
dedicated to their mother
the fact that there is this division
this huge rift between them
i think everyone hopes it can be sorted
out as prince harry acknowledged in the
interview
it's going to take time there's work to
be done and but i think really however
angry william is over this interview and
i'm told he is beyond livid
i think he does want a relationship with
his brother in the future
it was no secret of course that william
and harry had fallen out harry himself
said that they were on
different paths but i think what has
really upset william is
is kate being dragged into the interview
a few days before the wedding
she was upset about something
pertaining yes the issue was correct
about flower girl dresses
and it made me cry and it really hurt my
feelings
of course megan revealing um what
actually happened over that
bridesmaid dress fitting when according
to megan she ended up
in tears um not kate which was what had
been reported
in the media over here i think that this
argument that obviously happened behind
closed doors has been dragged back
up and the duchess has been involved has
really upset william he's very very
protective
of kate and it will be very upsetting
for him that she's been dragged into
this
i think the duchess will will also be
very upset and disappointed to have been
dragged in and megan was was very
generous about kate she said she's a
good person
it wasn't a confrontation and i actually
think it's
i don't think it's fair to her to get
into the details of that because she
apologized okay and i've forgiven her
right
i would hope that she would have wanted
that corrected and maybe in the same way
that the
palace wouldn't let anybody else negate
it they wouldn't let her because she's a
good person
and she didn't go into a huge amount of
detail but she did bring it all back up
and i think for kate who's always been
very discreet
you don't hear about her having rows or
falling out with people i think this
will be
very upsetting and and i do know the
behind the scenes you know kate really
has
tried to be a peacemaker and and
certainly tried to get the brothers back
on an even keel so
i think yeah she she will certainly be
upset to have been pulled into this
i think william and to a degree kate's
feelings will be that
this was a this was a private episode it
was it was dealt with according
to megan kate apologized and apparently
she sent flowers so i think they would
have considered it
mata clothes what what was i think they
would have
i think the cambridges would have hoped
that it was the end of the matter i
think they will be upset that it has all
been dragged up again